[Musique]
etes-vous choqué non et par quoi me
direz vous quoi de plus banal en effet
pardon de plus courant une femme en
pantalon
elles sont au moins aussi nombreuses et
sans doute plus nombreuses que les
hommes qui porte le cheveu long
elle se montre ainsi publiquement avec
la plus large des contractions et
pourtant pourtant toutes ces femmes sont
hors la loi et ne le savent même pas
[Musique]
or madame je constate que vous portez le
pantalon excuses à une autorisation la
préfecture de police pour le faire non
est ce que vous savez que théoriquement
vous devriez en avoir une autorisation
sais pas il existe une loi qui vous
oblige ou à ne pas porter vêtements
masculins ou alors à demander
l'autorisation
ces dépôts participe aux pouces est
peut-être due forme mais ce n'est pas
nouveau ça date de 1800 journal officiel
de 260 présente et oui en effet ce n'est
pas une blague c'est au contraire tout
ce qu'il ya de plus sérieux
la preuve le préfet de police informée
que beaucoup de femmes se travestissent
est persuadé qu'aucune d'elles ne quitte
les habite son sexe que pour cause de
santé
alors après quelques considérant article
2 toute femme désirant s'habiller en
homme devra se présenter à la préfecture
de police pour en obtenir l'autorisation
article 3 cette autorisation ne sera
donnée que sur le certificat d'un
officier de santé dont la signature sera
dûment légalisée et en outre sur
l'attestation des mères ou commissaire
de police portant les noms prénoms
profession et demeure de la requérante
article 4 toute femme trouvée travesti
qui ne sera pas ce qui ne sera pas
conformé aux dispositions des articles
précédents sera arrêtée et conduite la
préfecture de police vient fin de compte
cette ordonnance préfectoral est en
vigueur depuis cent soixante treize ans
maintenant il semble puisque
personnellement je n'ai pas retrouvé de
texte abrogeant ce texte du cesb rumeurs
hommes du président dans quelle mesure
une loi datant de 1800 de l'ordre 9 et
qui n'a pas été abrogée peut encore être
appliquée et en principe toute loi toute
réglementation qui n'a pas été abrogée
demeure en vigueur
il est bien certain qu'une telle
réglementation qui ne se conçoit plus
dans l'état de nos moeurs ne serait
certainement plus impliqués bien entendu
et surtout ne sanctionner en sommes
navrés voulait les femmes qui portent
encore le pantalon qui le portent de
plus en plus à vrai dire ne prennent
aucun risque vis à vis des lois or je le
pense d'ailleurs des poursuites en
pareille matière serait vraiment d'un
ridicule achevé sans aucun doute en
effet vous pouvez donc mesdames sans
trop vous exposer aux rigueurs des
textes vous vêtir de pantalons la loi
pour une fois restera mieux et puis
finalement les modes successives ont
fait que vous pouvez facilement
contourné les préceptes légaux
l'interdiction de porter des vêtements
masculins swaps
mais le pantalon est il encore de nos
jours exclusivement masculin alors à
votre avis est ce que je sais masculin
de porter un pantalon
je m'inquiète parce qu'elle n'est plus
là
personnellement je veux tu
chanteuse est aussi esthétique de voir
ce que de voir certaines filles avec des
jus qui sont une horrible maltais une
femme peut être féministe moment
pourtant frontale sera de 20 m à un
enseignant savez ce n'est pas parce
qu'il comprend ces pratiques c'est n'ai
pas eu l'impression de porter des
vêtements masculins
non non non parce qu'on peut le punissez
je pense pas avoir l'air de le garçu les
confronte à lons
[Musique]